The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from 100s of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I promised
everybody that we
would have the
capability of testing
a multi-junction solar cell.
We've been working so far with
a single-junction crystalline
silicon.
And just to refresh
everybody about what
a multi-junction device is, it
is a high-efficiency concept.
The efficiencies
that are obtained
under concentrated
sunlight are above 40%
now with some of these
high-efficiency concentrated
devices.
And again, the way this
concentrated device works
is if you have, for example,
germanium, gallium arsenide
indium, gallium
phosphide stack--
three different materials, three
different band gaps ranging
from somewhere in
the range of 0.67
eV all the way up to a few eV.
The largest band gap
is placed at the top,
because the short wavelength
light is absorbed by that one,
and the longer wavelength lights
go through and are absorbed
by the layers underneath.
So you can think about this
as blue, orange, and red,
if you like to see things in
colors, the short wavelength
light being the blue absorbed at
the top, the sunlight obviously
coming in through that
side through the top,
the middle cell absorbing the
light somewhere in the middle
of the solar spectrum, and
the bottom cell into the reds.
So the notion is to
have a device that
is capable of minimizing
thermalization losses.
So the short wavelength
light, instead
of being absorbed in
a low bandgap material
and generating a ton
of heat in the process,
is able to be absorbed very
efficiently via that top cell.
And only the longest wavelength
light, the lowest energy light,
makes it down to the small
bandgap material underneath.
So this is representative
of the stack of materials
that we have.
I believe what
we're going to do is
do a direct comparison of
silicon versus multi-junction.
Is that right?
Yeah, so right now we have
installed the silicon devices.
Those are the very
nicely encapsulated ones.
We had to change
the light source.
As you see now, we have a little
bit of a flashlight there.
Why is that?
Why did we have
to go from an LED,
a monochromatic light source,
to a broadband flashlight?
AUDIENCE: Well, if
the point is that you
have these different
absorbing layers that
absorb different
wavelengths of light,
if you only put one
[? group ?] like that,
the other layers
wouldn't have any effect.
PROFESSOR: And it kind
of defeats the purpose.
Plus the current outputs of
these three different cells
have to be more or less matched.
So because they're
connected in series,
if you have a poor performing
cell-- or one component, one
sub-cell, if you will--
that is generating
a small amount of
current, that will
limit the combined current
output of the entire stack.
Good.
So why don't we go ahead and
connect them to our computers.
We have our tech support
staff available on call--
who just walked
out, conveniently,
but will be back momentarily.
We'll connect them
to our computers,
fire it up, and team
up with somebody
if you don't happen to
have a computer with you.
We'll get this demo started.
So the notion here is to first
test the silicon-based device.
Once we have a good
working IV curve
out of the silicon-based
device, we'll take a pause.
We'll talk about
what we would expect
to see from the
multi-junction device
when we hook that one up.
So why don't we go to
it and give it a shot.
So let me dive into
what is effectively
our last in-class
lecture before we
are graced with some
really nice presentations.
I'm looking forward to those.
So global trends--
what I decided
to talk the last
day about-- really
we have a couple of
topics left, which
we don't have time to cover.
We won't have time
to cover both.
We'll have time to cover
one but not the other.
And the two topics are the
future of R&D in solar.
And the other topic is solar
in developing countries.
And I think both are
equally important.
I decided to pick the former
rather than the latter.
Global investments, trends in
solar and other renewables--
what I wanted to do
was to briefly walk
through some of
the recent trends
in R&D. So energy
companies traditionally
are not R&D spenders.
They reinvest a
very small fraction
of their profits in R&D, in
research and development.
And solar, because it is far
from grid parity right now--
factor of two or factor of three
in terms of cost-- not price,
cost-- we have to invest
R&D to get the cost down.
And this is both manufacturing
innovation and, of course,
engineering
scientific innovation.
So this right here is
financial investment
in clean energy, global
trends by quarter.
I decided to
compile as much data
as I possibly could
into the slides
so that you can go on
afterward, if you're
really interested in the
topic, pursue it further.
And what we see is as a
rise overall of investment
in so-called clean energy.
And by and large,
by the G20-- these
are countries that have access
to resources, to capital--
larger GDPs on average.
You also see a trend and in non
G20 countries, more recently,
an uptick or recognition that
this is an important area.
And perhaps there's room to
play, niches if you will,
that certain countries can
adopt that would provide
a competitive advantage.
This is an interesting
chart as well.
This shows the investment in-- I
believe this is government R&D.
Oh, this is financial
sector investment only,
excludes corporate
and government R&D--
small distributed capacity
in both-- so financial sector
investment in the US and China.
What we see in the US is
relatively stable investment--
picked up in the mid 2000s, but
relatively stable throughout.
And in China, just
a really steady
increase here of a R&D funding.
Note the role of the market
in the United States.
Right around '05 and '06, this
was when the price of PV began
to plateau.
The costs continue coming down,
but the price of PV modules
began to plateau because of
the silicon feedstock shortage.
So people saw opportunity
here, especially
the financial sector,
private capital, and said,
hey, if prices
are remaining high
and the costs are
coming down, that
means our profit
margin is growing.
This is a good industry for
us to get into-- a high profit
margin industry.
So there are many folks
getting in because
of that market condition.
Some of them saw the future
in the market and said,
this is trending
towards commodities.
We have to adopt that
mentality, and really
squeeze every penny out of our
cost structure that we can do.
And others went into
it thinking that this
would be a bumper crop-- a
really high yield investment.
And then as the margins began to
get squeezed, they got scared,
and some pulled out.
So it's an interesting
trend, following the market
perturbations in
the United States
and having this fluctuation.
And in China, from what I can
tell discussing with business
leaders and politicians,
a much more premeditated,
long-term strategy saying
this is a strategic industry
for our country.
We are going to invest in it.
And this is of fundamental
national importance.
So a little bit of difference
in the investment strategies
of the two.
The EU is a little bit
in between-- a mixed bag.
Again, this uptick in
the middle of the 2000s,
but a continued investment
in PV and renewables.
This shows the investment
type by sector, broken down
on the right-hand side between
the renewable energy types.
So you have wind, solar,
other renewables, biofuels,
and so-called negawatts,
so-called energy efficiency.
And on the left-hand side,
we have the different types
of investment into clean tech.
And interestingly, here
in the United States--
this is in 2009--
venture capital
is comprising a surprising
total of the investment
in renewable energy.
And in terms of
the sector itself,
we can see solar here in
the United States comprising
a large percentage, again,
of the total investment.
I want to bring caution to one
data point up there-- Spain.
That was a little bit
of a short-term fluke.
The Spanish government
instituted a feed-in tariff
similar to what Germany
has implemented,
but a little less successfully.
Let me dive into the details.
Germany did a careful
market analysis,
was the first to
move into the space,
and began dominating the market
for PV-- 50% of PV installed.
So if Germany set the
price a little differently,
the PV market would
adjust accordingly.
Spain, a new entrant,
seeing Germany's success,
decided to replicate it.
The first time they
attempted a feed-in tariff,
their feed-in tariff
came in too low,
and the market looked at Spain,
shrugged their shoulders,
and continued
installing in Germany.
The second time they
decided to come in,
they put their feed-in
tariff a little bit too high.
And as a result, the market
said, really, you kidding?
OK, we go there and install.
And there was a slush of
modules over to Spain,
flooding the market.
And over a period of
about a year to two years,
they got much more than
they bargained for.
In other words, they had many,
many more modules installed
than they had expected.
And now the government
has to pay out
to these installed systems.
They have to pay
out a certain rate
based on the feed-in tariff.
And it was more than they
expected to have to pay out.
Then the financial crisis hits.
So it was a little
bit of a disaster,
because they ended up
killing the program,
killing in the process
about 10 years of work
to design the program, 10
years of institution building
to think about how to create
a feed-in tariff for Spain,
and without the
desired result, which
was a slow, steady increase of
the photovoltaic installations
in Spain and hence,
the local industry.
So it was a little
bit of a flash
in the pan-- a huge market
that burst very suddenly,
and then quickly
extinguished itself.
So it's a good
example of how not
to perform a feed-in tariff, how
not to design a feed-in tariff.
So in 2009, that was the end
of the bumper year investment.
Spain also did something
that was pretty nasty
from a government
policy point of view.
They decided to retroactively
change their feed-in tariff.
AUDIENCE: Ooh.
PROFESSOR: Ooh, so
a feed-in tariff
is a contract between
the government--
or the utility--
and the installer,
saying that we will pay
a certain amount per year
for a number of years.
And to go back on that,
renege on the feed-in tariff--
that's a no-no.
It undermines market confidence.
So the PV module
prices-- I just wanted
to highlight this
slide once again,
to highlight the market
conditions that are
being experienced right now.
We had, in the mid 2000s, a rise
in, or fairly steady prices.
And meanwhile, costs
were coming down.
This, by the way is
price, but in thin films
for solar cad-tel,
these blue dots
here being crystalline silicon.
And the prices
remained fairly steady.
And then in, say,
2008 to 2011, prices
have dropped precipitously.
The 2011 numbers here are
at or slightly below $1.
So you can see,
for somebody who is
being driven by
market conditions,
this is extremely unsettling.
And it causes capital to
fluctuate back and forth.
Now the same thing--
what is happening here
in the solar
modules, the inverse
is happening in
the installations.
So the installers are seeing the
price of their modules go down
and the price of
their installations
declining steadily,
but more or less
staying fixed because of the
investment tax credit staying
fixed and so forth in the US,
and utility prices rising.
And so the installers are
saying, hey, this is great.
So their profit
margins are really big.
Warning to anybody trying
to get into the sector right
now-- think carefully
about these market dynamics
in the United States
and in Europe,
and how that will
affect your business.
If you're trying to get
into the solar absorber,
as in module,
manufacturing business,
or if you're trying to get into
the equipment manufacturing
business, or in the
installation side in the grid,
think about how these
market dynamics are
going to affect your business
as it grows and tries to gain
a foothold in this environment.
It's a great time to
be a new installer
company, but in three or
four years, when we're
in an under-supplied
condition again,
and prices might even
go up, what then?
So think about these topics.
We're talking about renewable
energy R&D and the technology
pipeline.
So it's important to
recognize the path
that many of these
new technologies
take to go from concept or idea
into full-scale manufacturing.
So in general, this is the path
followed in the United States.
And we have technology research
happening in places like this,
at MIT.
The roll-out, in other
words, the installations
and large-scale manufacturing
on the other side.
And there are many funding
sources available for that--
not so much this last one
here in the United States,
but maybe in
Australia or Europe,
in select regions of the US.
This technology development
right here in the middle
has been what is referred
to as the Valley of Death.
Does anybody know why-- what
that means, Valley of Death?
What is it?
AUDIENCE: A period when it's
difficult to get funding
from any source.
PROFESSOR: It's a period when
it's difficult to get funding
from any source.
Now imagine you're a group
of postdocs and students
in the lab.
You come up with a
new, fancy technology,
and you can't quite
get the venture
capital or private equity
necessary to kick off
your company.
That would be one
mini-valley of death.
It's fairly avoided here in US.
Good ideas have a tendency
to get funded at that stage.
But if you don't get
funded, then the postdoc
gets another position
over here, becomes
a professor at university
across the country.
The student goes off and does
a postdoc in another place.
And all of a sudden, three,
five, six months later,
the venture capital
swirls around
to the professor,
who's still here at MIT
and kind of has a hollowed-out
group at this point, and says,
wow that's a great idea.
I'd like to invest in it.
Where's your team?
Yeah, poof.
So that's one possible
mechanism wherein technologies
don't make it forward.
And so keeping the team
together is extremely important.
The second Valley
of Death can happen
right between technology
development and manufacturing
and scale-up.
We've seen some of these.
We've seen pictures of
some of the factories.
They're around here
in the countryside.
These are oftentimes
$10s, more likely $100s
of millions investments.
And venture capital
funds tend to be
on the order of $100s of
millions to $1 billion.
They don't like investing
in large asset goods.
They don't like
investing in factories.
They'd rather invest in
a small group of people
with the computers
set in their garage,
maybe put in a couple
$10s of thousands
and turn around, profit
of a few million.
That's the type
of investment that
makes a lot of sense
for venture capital.
When you start investing
in fixed goods-- in brick
and mortar-- you need
other forms of financing.
And some countries
around the world
have been very adept in
providing this financing.
China, in particular,
has done a great job
at making that type of financing
available for companies
that are small and
looking to expand.
But in the United States,
it's very difficult
to access these essentially
money from banks, especially,
for new technology.
The bank will say, well,
why am I investing in you?
I could be investing
in something
that's much more sure of a bet--
today's technology, instead of
investing in something risky.
So the government has stepped
in with a variety of programs
to try to ease that
inefficiency in the market.
And so one of the
means are loans--
loan guarantee program, for
example, is one mechanism.
There is a [? sunPATH ?]
program that
is coming down the
pipeline as well.
So we have venture capital
and private equity,
but that can only take
you so far, typically.
They invest a few
$10s of millions,
in a few rare cases, a
few $100s of millions.
But then they reach the end of
their credit line, if you will.
They exhaust their
ability to invest.
And what's needed to
expand manufacturing
is typically on the order
of $100s of millions
to billions of dollars to reach
100s of megawatts-- gigawatt
scale.
So that's the second big Valley
of Death in the United States
that exists.
And the way some companies
are transitioning
across that valley-- they
find a variety of means.
Some go overseas.
They say, hey, the
Central Bank of China
is willing to
invest money in me.
I go there.
I set up manufacturing.
Other companies, small
companies, might say, well, GE,
you have a big finance group
within your big umbrella
company.
Why don't you buy us?
And then we can gain
access to capital
and expand our
manufacturing plant.
Others form
partnerships with banks.
It's a mixed set of
business strategies.
But if you look around at some
of the start-up companies that
are now entering
small-scale production,
this is where the business side
of creativity comes in play.
And that's where you really
need a good business developer
at hand to arrange
those deals for you.
In terms of where the money
is, in terms of clean tech
in general, these are some
figures in terms of 2009 data.
I'm sure we can get some more
up-to-date figures as well.
And in terms of
growth and investment,
we see some countries that might
be rather surprising in terms
of the five-year growth of
investment in renewables.
Obviously, if you start
from a very small number,
you can grow pretty quick
in terms of percents.
But it's still interesting
to see the development
of some countries here.
This is sobering.
So this is the US government
R&D by budget function '55
to '97, the most comprehensive
data set I could find.
I'm sure that there
are graphs that
extend this into the future.
If you happen to have one,
I'd be happy to see it.
But the basic
story of this graph
is the following-- the
lion's share of R&D
is going to the
Defense Department,
so the Army Research
Office, Office
of Naval Research, DARPA--
that's the advanced research
program-- a variety of night
vision labs, and so forth.
These are a variety of defense
R&D. And there is trickle down.
There's some trickle down of
technologies being developed
in defence into civilian uses.
And so I don't want
to point to this
and say it's a bogey
man-- by no means.
But it does indicate
national priorities
in terms of R&D research.
The other big one is health.
So NIH, National
Institutes of Health--
that's growing and expanding.
It's very easy to
go to congresspeople
and senators who might be
advancing in their years,
and say, hey, we need money
for Alzheimer's research,
or we need money
for cancer research.
It resonates.
It's easy to convince
people of that.
Energy is small, traditionally.
Let me dive forward into this
going a little bit further.
This is non-defense R&D
funding pushed out to 2004.
Again, you can see health
really driving things.
Energy, traditionally-- in
the Jimmy Carter years right
around here, it expanded a bit.
This was a renewables burst.
That's where the National
Renewable Energy Laboratory
was founded, originally called
the Solar Energy Research
Institute or SERI.
And then got crimped down
again and really experienced
a bit of a pinch in the US
right when solar was really
beginning to take off in Japan.
So this is when solar
cell production by Sharp
was really beginning to climb in
the late '90s and early 2000s.
And then, of course,
Germany followed
and the rest of the world.
So we've been a little
bit behind, step by step.
And the interesting thing that
many people have looked into
is, what sort of correlation
exists between US government
R&D spending and
output of new ideas.
And the output of new ideas,
the metric that they're
using for this are patents.
So you could dispute that.
You could say, well, patents
aren't the best indicator
of new ideas.
Sometimes new ideas
are diffuse benefits,
and they help all industries,
but you can't really
patent the idea.
Fine, but this is, I think, the
most quantitative comparison
that folks have performed.
This is an interesting
study where
folks looked at the
number of patents granted
and energy R&D
funding and plotted it
as a function of year, and
saw a strong correlation
between uptick of national
priority and government
funding and innovation.
So this was the first
wave of innovation
in energy, and in
PV specifically,
in the late 1970s when the OPEC
oil crisis hit in the United
States and there was a big
push for renewable energy
development.
Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: Just
patents in energy or--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly,
so these are pushed down.
And we can dive into
patents just for PV,
which is this graph right here.
And this is an updated
version of that earlier
study by Dan Kammen.
This earlier stuff study
by Robert Margolis.
Robert Margolis is now at
NREL, National Renewable Energy
Laboratory, and he works
on market assessment there.
Gregory Nemet was a
student at the time
with Dan Kammen, produced
this wonderful continuation
of the study published
a few years later.
And again, broke it down
into specific technologies,
including photovoltaics,
and saw, again,
some correlation between
the number of patents
and public R&D. In the mid
2000s, this really-- the number
of patents and started to
grow as startup companies got
into the fray.
Remember when prices stayed
flat and costs continued
coming down, and those margins
increased, a bunch of players
got into that space and
said, we could make money.
So a number of
patents were filed.
A number of startup
companies got off the ground.
Again, funding-patent
correlation
for energy in general--
I provide you the data.
You can dive into it
in more detail if you,
not only PV but other
technologies-- interesting.
Global trends in
venture investing--
since venture
investing is important
for you specifically,
it's one of the pathways
to get ideas out
of the university
and into a startup company.
We talked about this so far.
And OK, so we're diving
a little bit deeper here.
This is for the venture capital
private equity financing
by sector in 2009,
looking specifically
at solar in the United
States, comprised
a large fraction of it.
Solar continues to comprise
a large fraction of venture
investment, surprisingly,
despite the market conditions
right now.
Because folks, especially
in the VC community,
are looking at today's
market as an opportunity.
They think that if enough people
are scared out of the market,
that they'll be able to
remain there and pick up
the good ideas.
And if they're only a little bit
smarter than their competition,
they can pick up
the right companies
and the right sections
of the value chain--
maybe an equipment
manufacturer, maybe an installer
with a new idea-- and avoid
some of the pain that's
going on right now in
wafer fabrication and cell
fabrication upstream.
This was the VC
investment in solar right
here in those boom
years that I mentioned.
So during the years when prices
started to plateau because
of the silicon feedstock
shortage in the mid 2000s,
you saw this massive
uptick of investment
in venture capital funding.
That scale is in
millions of dollars.
You're exceeding $1 billion of
VC funding in solar in 2007.
And that trend
continued in 2008.
So still to this
day, we're seeing
$100s of millions plowed into
solar by venture capital funds.
It's interesting,
really interesting.
The number of startup
companies in the United States
has proliferated.
There are, I think,
somewhere on the order
of over 200 solar startup
companies worldwide.
There are a few
that have failed.
So Wakonda, Solasta, SV Solar,
Synergen, Optisolar, Solyndra,
SpectraWatt, Evergreen
Solar-- these are all I'd
say failed companies,
by the definition
of failure-- bankruptcy.
I mean, by that metric, so
is United Airlines failed,
and American Airlines failed.
They're still around.
They restructured under
bankruptcy protection.
Some have closed
their doors entirely.
Other ones have restructured,
or are in the process
of restructuring.
Why each of these
companies have failed?
Different reasons.
You can't claim that each one
had the exact same trajectory.
But you can definitely point
to certain market conditions
as influencing or
precipitating the failure.
Let me be more specific.
These companies right here are
all wafer or thin-film device
and module manufacturers.
They're the upstream components.
These aren't
installation companies.
These aren't installers failing.
These are upstream
manufacturers failing--
and a few high-profile
ones at that.
So that was precipitated by
the recent market conditions--
the capital crunch.
It begins with some
of the companies,
say OptiSolar in
2009, I believe.
They were a company that was
producing amorphous silicon
modules.
And as we studied
amorphous silicon,
the efficiencies are low, right?
The amorphous silicon
module efficiency's
on the order of 6%.
And they said, well,
never mind that our cost
structure's a little high.
We're going to scale up
like nobody's business.
We're going to ramp up
manufacturing capacity
to over a gigawatt, and do
it really, really quick.
And just by sheer
scale alone, we'll
be able to drive down costs
and get us to the point
where we're competitive on a
cents per kilowatt hour basis
with crystalline silicon.
There's a great
business plan in theory.
But what happened to them
was, when they went out
to try to raise money, they
couldn't find any right
around 2008.
It was the beginning of
the financial crisis.
So they had the
business plan in mind.
And on paper, it looked great.
But when it came time to
raise the funding to grow,
they didn't have it, even
though they had a guaranteed
customer-- PG&E. That
was the Pacific Gas
and Electric, the
California utility.
They just could not
get the financing
to expand their factory.
So what ended up
happening was they folded,
sold the supply stream, if
you will, to First Solar,
who picked it up for
pennies on the dollar.
And First Solar modules ended
up going in the PG&E field
installations, instead of the
OptiSolar amorphous silicon.
Each company has its
own story, and have
failed for different reasons.
What's clear is also, there are
more failed start-ups coming.
This is a time of a
financial pain for them.
The prices are very, very low.
And there are a few people
who are tracking these startup
companies.
I would say Eric Wesoff
from Greentech Media
is probably one
of the most active
in publishing his insights.
That said, there are many
promising companies among here,
and some of these, hopefully,
will become household names
for good reasons in the future,
as they have an innovation that
significantly drives down
cost over their competitors.
We're going to get to
that in a few slides.
We're going to talk about
how to evaluate a company.
Because it's going to
be important for you--
near term because
you might want a job,
or you might want to
form your own company,
long term because you might
become an investor in PV.
And you have to figure out what
types of companies make sense
to invest in, and which don't.
In terms of startup companies
in the New England area,
we often think of ourselves
as kind of maybe second fiddle
to Silicon Valley.
But there's a lot
going on in the region,
and a lot of good work.
So if you go to
cleanenergycouncil.org cluster
map, you'll see a map
of the local clean tech
companies in the region.
I'll leave this slide
up there, since I
see a few of you jotting notes.
It's a useful map, and
you can select by sector
as well, if you look at solar,
look at biofuels, and so forth.
Trends in renewable energy
manufacturing-- this slide
is a little bit outdated,
but it's the Greentech Media
research map of manufacturing
in the United States
of the different
solar technologies--
again, a bit outdated.
There are a few companies
that have changed.
But it gives you a sense of
what the distribution is.
What are the latest
trends of manufacturing
in the United States?
The latest trends
of manufacturing,
if I were to point
to a few of them--
Mississippi has emerged as
a big manufacturing state.
Why?
First off, who's from
the Southeast here?
Show of hands-- one, two.
All right, what do you have in
this region right around here
that the rest of the
country doesn't have?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Close, coal--
you have a lot of coal.
You have nuclear as well.
The TVA-- does anybody
know what the TVA is?
Tennessee Valley
Authority-- that's
a big public works project,
in fact, that got started.
It provides low-cost electricity
to this entire region
right up here, including
northern Mississippi,
including some of
the northern portions
of the far Southeast states.
Bottom line-- you have
depressed wages, by and large,
in these rural communities, and
low-cost electricity-- which
if labor and utilities
matter-- which
it does in solar manufacturing--
it's ripe for manufacturing.
And you have many startup
companies-- Stion, Calisolar,
Twin Creeks, and others that
have moved into the Mississippi
region in very recent
months for that reason.
You have Suniva was based
in Georgia, Atlanta.
Ohio still continues to be.
The Northwest as well-- cheap
hydro, not exactly cheap wages,
but cheap hydro.
And the technologies do tend
to stay closer to the places
where they are born.
You can see in the San
Francisco Bay Area,
there's a propensity to
form startup companies
in new technologies as well
as in the Massachusetts area.
So these are focusing on some of
the medium-scale manufacturers.
In terms of
manufacturing support,
this is what local
state governments
are doing to help form new
companies in the United States.
You have, as well, a variety
of mechanisms-- grants, loans,
tax credits, and so forth
for new factories that
are trying to start up.
So keep that in mind
if you're going for it.
And market incentives-- in terms
of the three-- Germany, US,
and China-- you also have to
consider Korea, Japan, India,
Brazil, other countries
as well in this mix,
if you really want a
global perspective.
But this dumbs it down to three.
In terms of what
incentives are available
for different
countries, there is
a plethora of
different incentives
which can help the market pull.
OK, so we go back and
have a clearer picture
of what's happening, at least
in the US with its investment--
the VC investments as
well as manufacturing,
the next step on
the state level.
So we're collecting
some data points there.
This is interesting.
If your money is from
the bank, let's say,
and you're paying an
interest rate on it
and you want to
start a new factory,
but then your local inspector
comes back to you and says,
well, we're going to have to
delay by three months because
of reason x, y and z.
Now you're paying interest
on the money, potentially.
But you're not generating
profits off of it.
So delays cost money.
Project delays cost money.
It's also an opportunity cost.
And so there was a study
done a few years ago
looking into why it is that
renewable energy projects are
delayed.
And they came up with some
interesting region-dependent
conclusions as a
result of this study--
whether it's transmission
limitations-- Texas, there have
even been cases in New
York of transmission lines
having limited capacity
for renewables-- financing
constraints, power purchase
agreement weaknesses,
permitting-- that could be a
big slow down if that's not
streamlined-- financing
and permitting,
and negligible local market.
And again, we see
the TVA popping up
here as a negligible
market for the renewables,
because, well, you
have cheap electricity.
It's hard to compete
against that.
But in other states with
more sun and more expensive
electricity, there's the
potential to install it.
But you may be limited,
in fact, by the grid.
There's a big new
study released,
I believe it was this week,
by the MIT Energy Initiative
on the future of the grid.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could you say
again what PPA stands for?
PROFESSOR: Power
Purchase Agreement--
so that's the incentive
mechanism whereby
you can begin putting the
solar panels on your roof,
and the installer
pays for the panels,
gets the money from the bank,
installs them on your roof.
You sign the contract
to pay a certain price
for the electricity over
the next 12, 15, 20 years.
So global trends in
R&D-- this is, again,
a data dump of several sources,
one from the NSF showing
industry R&D expenditures,
government, federal government,
and other.
You can see in the
United States--
this is across
all sectors here--
but really an inversion
of the role of industry
and federal government.
So when you hear
MIT, for instance,
going after large
companies and saying hey,
you should invest
in R&D here at MIT,
this is one of the
fundamental driving forces--
this inversion here, the decline
of federal government spending.
And as well, has resulted
in MIT looking elsewhere
for funding, not only industry.
The greatest gains in R&D
intensity in terms of the R&D
expenditure have been in Asia.
You can see on the right-hand
side of this chart,
China, Japan, and Korea
increasing the expenditure
from 1997 to 2007.
This was right before
the financial crisis hit.
In the US, holding relatively
constant as a percentage,
as a share of GDP.
Science and engineering
interest in Asia--
this is science and
engineering degrees
as the percentage
of new degrees.
You can see over here we have
Germany, Korea, and China.
Germany makes a lot of sense.
The Germans have about 44,000
engineering jobs in renewables
right now that are unfilled.
So they need people.
They need people to go to
Germany to get high-tech jobs.
China is a bit more
precarious, in the sense
that the supply and demand
is much more evenly matched.
And the growth of both are
increasing at steady rates.
So if the growth of
manufacturing and R&D
does not continue
to rise in China,
there's going to be an
oversupply of people.
And that can lead to
a number of problems.
And so it's very
important for China
over the next several years to
keep a strong, steady handle
on this growth, to
make growth manageable.
It's a good problem to have.
It's managing success.
But it could also lead to
some catastrophic consequences
if the system gets
out of balance.
In the United States,
well, I believe
this data came from 2005.
That was at the height
of financial engineering.
I would hope that
this number here
has increased a bit
since the collapse
of the financial markets,
and a recognition
that there are productive
ways of investing
one's talents and mental gifts.
Global research output
shifts towards Asia.
This is global research
R&D, share of science
and engineering articles.
So if you're starting from
a small amount and growing,
you're going to be, if you just
look in a percentage basis,
by necessity taking away a share
of the pie from another entity.
So as China grows, India grows,
the rest of the world grows.
The share of science and
engineering articles in the US
and in the EU begin
to drop-- essentially
the dominant players--
and in Japan as well.
Now, that's not
necessarily a bad thing
if the quality of the
articles is maintained,
and the total number of
articles continues to expand,
and we have the capacity to
keep up with the information.
So there's a threshold,
or a limit, to how much
we can absorb-- how
much new information
we can absorb per unit time.
So people are working on
more sophisticated ways
of gathering and assembling
this information,
especially using
computers nowadays,
that can help expedite
R&D. So a number
of trends happening on the
scientific side-- you're
involved with that.
High-tech trade balances
continue to widen.
This is the trade balance
in high technology goods, US
and China.
And so obviously,
Chinese economy
is trending away from--
still heavily invested
in raw materials--
but trending away
from that toward high-tech
manufactured goods.
And the US entering a
region of trade deficit
as a result of purchasing
those products.
So these are all trends
that have policymakers,
in particular,
concerned, and looking
at the future of
global competitiveness.
Technology evaluation--
let me spend
a couple of words bringing
all of what I've just said,
and everything over the
entire course, home to you.
So far we've talked about these
things in very ethereal terms.
It's useful information.
It will prove useful once
you begin applying it.
But we want to run through
a quick, little scenario
right here, where you're
asked to evaluate a new PV
technology.
Why?
Well, you might be applying
for a job at this company,
and they say they
have the greatest
thing since sliced bread.
And you want to put
on your thinking cap,
and evaluate whether
that's true or not.
You might have a new
idea or new innovation.
And you're trying to make the
tough call-- do I go forward
and establish a company
off of this idea?
Or do I have to go back and
turn the crank a few more times
to come up with the
next better idea that's
more worthy of investment?
You could be an investor.
You could have money
at your disposal,
and you could decide
what company to invest in
or what not to invest in.
So how do you go about this?
I'd say three
fundamental components.
And venture capitalists
might disagree with me,
or other people who have
different skill sets
might disagree with me.
But me, from this
perspective as an engineer,
I say first analyze the physics.
Figure out how this
technology works.
Because if you understand
how the technology works,
you can understand some of
the fundamental limitations.
You can understand
efficiency limits.
And you can predict, based
on pattern recognition,
how hard is it going to be
to obtain or to approach
those limitations?
Analyze the cost
scale potential,
meaning the potential to
scale up, and manufacturing.
This is really more in the
engineering science side.
And we've been
getting more into this
during the second and
third parts of the course.
And analyze markets--
this is definitely
the third part of the course.
So this begins to
pull it all together.
Let's start with
analyzing the physics.
We talked about
conversion efficiency
being a strong lever for cost.
That's way we're analyzing
conversion efficiency.
The way I would recommend
analyzing any PV technology
that they throw at
you would be thinking
about conversion efficiency
in terms of output
energy versus input energy.
And think about losses
along each step of the way.
If you have time with the R&D
department, sit down with them.
Sit down with some of
the chief engineers
and walk through
each of the steps,
going from a light photon
entering the device
to charge being collected
on the other side
with a certain current
voltage characteristic.
And keep in mind that
the total efficiency
is going to be
limited by whatever
the worst performer is.
And keep that picture in mind,
too-- [INAUDIBLE] big advice.
Customer needs-- the
next is analyzing what
makes your product special.
So where is it going to
fit into the big picture?
Is it going to run
with the big dogs?
Is it going to be an
on-grid application,
in which case cents
per kilowatt hour
really matter-- the price for
the electricity for a power
purchase agreement?
If you're just selling the
module, maybe dollars per watt
would be an important
metric as well.
Or are you going to one of
these other niche markets
right over here?
And are you going to
be a player there?
How big is that market?
These are some questions to ask.
Cost-- all right, so now we know
what our intended market is.
We know what our product
is going to look like.
We know the physics behind it.
In a bit, we'll know more
about the manufacturing.
We think about cost.
And we talked briefly
about this during class.
We had more of an in-depth
discussion with Doug.
That Excel spreadsheet, by the
way, will be available to you
so you can look through it,
and see how a cost analysis was
done for crystalline silicon,
and how you might adapt it
to your technologies.
But it's really important to
perform a cost performance
model for your technology so
that you can understand what
levers to pull, what
levers need to be pulled,
to increase your
parameter of merit,
whatever that parameter
of merit happens
to be for your
potential customer need.
Manufacturing technologies
and scale really
do play into this quite a bit.
And for many technologies, or
for many companies at least
in the Silicon
Valley area, there
might be 50 companies working
on the same material-- copper
indium gallium diselenide,
let's say, CIGS.
But they each have their
own deposition process,
and they're each
trying to develop
their own pieces of equipment
to manufacture this material.
So understanding the
basic differences
between the different
deposition systems is important.
And we walked through that
during our thin-films lecture.
So again, you have access
to this information,
and you can parse through
it in greater detail
should you need to.
Scaling of
manufacturing-- we talked
about resource availability.
We even had an in-class
debate about it,
about cadmium tellurium.
There are reports out there
which you have access to,
like this APS report on
critical energy materials.
And we understand that the
manufacturing and reserves
of these elements are not
equitably distributed.
In fact, they're concentrated
in certain regions of the world.
And so that might influence
the ultimate potential
of a certain
technology to scale.
And again, this is another
intelligent set of questions
that you can ask.
We understand a bit about
the market dynamics now.
We understand this is price.
We understand that
there was a bit
of a plateau in price
in the mid 2000s,
a precipitous drop over
the last three years,
and that's really changed the
way that investments and equity
look at the solar market.
In the mid 2000s, it
was all gangbusters.
Everybody was really
happy to throw
any money they had at solar.
Now people are a
lot more selective
in terms of what they invest in.
And this trend of
oversupply undersupply
is probably going to
continue for some time
if the integrated circuit
industry is any example
and model.
So we're likely to
see this continue.
What is your market timing?
It might be a really good
time to found an installation
company right now, if you
can scale, and grow quickly,
and you have the right niche.
But if you have a new idea
for a thin-film absorber,
it's important to
think critically about
where the market is going to
go over the next few years,
and how that impacts your
strategy as a company.
You might decide, well, the
market's kind of cold right
now for modules.
So why don't we hold
back on building
that large-scale manufacturing
plant until, say, 2014,
and invest really
heavily in R&D right now,
and stay small, without
the financial obligations
of a big manufacturing
line, until we really
nail the technology, and
have something good to go.
And plus, think about
our exit strategy.
Maybe we won't ramp up to be
a gigawatt or two gigawatt
company.
Maybe instead it's more
important to form partnerships
with companies that are
manufacturing cad-tel or CIGS
right now.
So our business
developer's going
to spend more time
chatting with the business
developers of First Solar
and other companies.
We also know a bit about
the financial incentives
from Germany and some of
the largest PV markets
in the world.
We know that China is going
to ramp up significantly
in terms of installations
over the next few years.
We know that the United States
will, as well, as the prices
continue to come down.
These are the PV
feed-in tariff rates
shown in blue and red
for different types
of installations, blue being
the large, freestanding systems,
the red being mostly
rooftop mounted systems.
So we saw that the feed-in
tariff rate in Germany
has come down versus time.
And the average electricity
price has gone up.
So we can begin predicting what
the role of market subsidies
will be when we try to roll out
our technology onto the grid.
And we can plot this, and
see how that will impact
our business model as well.
And lastly, we know that
about 99% of the solar panels
have yet to be made.
99% of the solar panels
So there's a lot
of potential here.
This, again, going back to
the very first lecture, where
we had new energy
installations, new
PV installations
growing significantly.
Convergence is coming.
Who's going to comprise-- who's
going to the bridge that gap?
Who is going to be the
maker of the technology that
will ultimately bring PV to
a massive scale in the grid?
That's for you to decide.
So other intangibles in
terms of evaluating companies
would include the team,
especially the leadership team.
What is their track record?
What is their philosophy
of running the company?
The financing that's
available-- how much cash
is at hand-- the patent
portfolio, how protected
are they, and so forth.
Patents, by the way vary
in importance from the US
to certain other
regions of the world.
It's very important
in the US and Europe,
less important in China.
But it depends.
If a certain idea
is patented, you
will have difficulty
accessing that market.
You will have difficulty selling
product into that market,
even though you can continue
to sell a product into markets
that value patents less in IP.
So let's go through
a few examples.
I'm going to throw a couple
of examples at you real quick,
and just spout off the first
ideas that come to you.
How would you
analyze this company?
Solar paint.
All right, so I have my big
spray paint system here,
and I go to the side of
the house, and I go shh.
And that saves me a bundle
on installation costs.
It's easy.
You can do it
yourself, and you just
connect a few wires and voila,
you have solar electricity.
What would be your
first instinct?
AUDIENCE: How does it work?
PROFESSOR: How does it work?
[CLAPPING] Bravo, bravo.
What is the physics behind it?
How do you separate charge?
If you go back to this right
over here-- light absorption,
charge excitation is important.
What's the [? bang-up ?]
of the material?
How does it excite charge
inside of the material?
Where's charge separated?
How do carriers reach
those separation points?
You're just spraying on
one homogeneous layer?
Did I get that right?
There's not two layers?
Does it phase separate?
How does that work?
And in charge
collection, how are you
collecting the charge
over that massive area?
What are your resistive losses?
And so forth.
You're equipped now
to ask those questions
as a result of this course.
That's pretty awesome.
You think about it,
you're pretty empowered.
So it could work.
Solar paint could
very well work.
So it's important not to
ride into this discussion
on a high horse
and say ooh, won't
work because of x, y and z.
It's important to
keep an open mind,
because new ideas are
really quite startling,
and they can be game changing.
But it's important to have
a critical yet respectful
approach to this.
A critical mind is
always a good thing
to have on your shoulders.
Wundermaterial-- so I'm
arriving to you, and I say,
this is the wonder material.
It's all earth abundant,
totally scalable,
but I'm not going to
tell you what it is.
So you're going to have
to invest in my company
because I have this great
team right here-- a great team
coming from Intel.
I used to be a head manager
at a national laboratory.
I know my stuff.
I really know my PV.
I can wow you with a few
presentations about PV device
physics, and talk
all this fancy stuff.
But you're going to have
to invest in my company
based in a few SCM
images, plain-view SCM
images of the
material structure,
just to prove that I
can actually deposit it.
But I'm not going to tell
you what the material is,
because US VC's could
run off with my idea
and go sell it to somebody else.
So I'm going to hold that
very close to my chest.
Do you invest in me or not?
AUDIENCE: Depends on
what you're asking for.
PROFESSOR: Depends on
what you're asking.
Depends how much
you're asking for.
That was a real situation.
I was in that room.
I was evaluating that company.
And as a scientist in that room,
I was, like, are you serious?
You can't be serious.
The venture
capitalists, however,
thought differently, and said,
look, the team is really good.
And for reasons that
were described--
I can't get into all
of them without giving
the details away--
there were reasons
for investing in that particular
case, in that company.
And even though the
physics was not understood,
and even though the ultimate
efficiency potential was not
understood, the VC firm
made an investment.
So far it's been going
OK with that company.
So just to point
out that this is
a base, a foundation of
which to make decisions.
It's not a prescription upon
A lot of things factor in.
Use your best judgment.
You're the one best equipped
to make those decisions.
Path forward-- this is
kind of my last few words
on the soapbox before I hand
over the microphones to you.
The path forward,
from my perspective--
the markets are going to drive
a lot of the public story.
But you know that cost
matters more than price.
Price is the
short-term market pull.
During the mid 2000s--
actually, down here
when the price was
still very, very high,
solar was kind of this hippie,
tree-hugging group of nerds
that would get together
at the Muddy Charles
and come up with the facts-based
analysis, which formed the MIT
Energy Club--
really small thing.
And then right when the
prices began to stabilize
and there was this view
that energy was a huge gold
mine waiting to be explored,
a massive amount of interest
came into the field--
and growth, accordingly.
And it was good.
But in the 2008 and so forth,
we had this precipitous drop
in prices, as well as
the collapse of finance
to allow these
technologies to scale up.
The Valley of Death widened and
deepened a bit, if you will.
And suddenly, energy looked
a lot more precarious.
I started having students
come into my office
doing interviews, saying what
sort of career can I have here?
Tell me, seriously,
are their jobs
waiting for me when I exit?
The reality is, there
are jobs waiting
for bright, smart people
regardless of the market
condition.
There were jobs back here.
There will be jobs in the
future as well, if you're
good at what you do and you
ask the right questions,
conduct good
experiments, and know
how to disseminate your work.
But this is kind of
a return to the roots
now, where we have
people who are in solar
and interested in solar who are
really there for the long run.
And so knowing the
market conditions really
helps you put everything
into perspective,
and see how the situation
might evolve going forward.
In terms of tipping point,
it's largely agreed upon
that $1 a watt system
installed is really
where we want to head to.
So we know the cost right
now of manufacturing
a PV module of
crystalline silicon
is on the order of $1 per watt.
And if you're inventing
a new technology,
you have to do half of that.
And crystalline silicon has a
roadmap to get to about $0.50
per watt peak by 2020, 2025.
And so if you're developing
a new technology,
you have to undercut that
and some way, shape or form.
And you can do that
in a variety of ways--
improving the efficiency.
There's a lot of headroom in
efficiency-- lot of headroom
there-- maybe at manufacturing
scale and so forth.
But if a technology,
some technology by 2020,
can get to $1 a watt installed,
we're looking at, by 2030,
a pretty massive,
good penetration of PV
across the United States.
And that's just the start of it.
The US is just the
drop in the bucket.
This is the world.
There's a lot of people--
1.6 billion of them,
approximately-- without
electricity right now.
They're coming online.
And they're driving the majority
of the growth in CO2 emissions.
Majority of the growth
comes from two points-- one,
we're outsourcing our CO2.
If you look at the amount of CO2
the United States contributes
to the world, it might
be 1/5, but if you
look at all the manufactured
goods, all the clothes we're
wearing right now, all of the
apparatus that we're using,
these were manufactured
probably not in the US,
but they're here for
our consumption and use.
We own that carbon.
That's our carbon.
We're responsible for it.
So our footprint
increases further.
So we're outsourcing the carbon.
It's growing in certain
developing regions
that are exporting to us.
And secondly,
they're also growing.
They're also consuming.
They're also getting cars,
and computers, and so forth.
So there's an overall growth of
consumption around the world.
We agree that climate
change is an issue.
And we look at the
solar insolation map,
and we say, wow, compared
to certain minerals,
or rare earths, or petroleum,
this is fairly equitably
distributed.
Even regions, say in Patagonia
or up in northern Europe,
compared to the
Equator-- we're looking
about a 3x, maybe 4x
delta in solar resource,
not a million to 1.
We're looking at a 4x delta
in solar resource, which
is not that big of a spread.
And furthermore, if we go back
and look at the countries that
are really coming
online, just using
this loose parameter of
human development index
that we referred to on
the first day of class,
we can see that the countries
with the largest solar resource
base-- several of
them also happen
to be countries that are on
the path toward development,
on the path toward consumption.
And solar can really have
an impact in those countries
to improve the quality
of life, and also
reduce carbon emissions
overall in the world.
So what role can you play?
I mean, I think important
things to keep in mind
is, we're really at
the beginning of solar.
We have a lot of
headroom to grow.
I think the amount of venture
capital investment loss so far
due to failed
companies is a drop
in the bucket compared to GDP.
It's a drop in the
bucket compared
to military investments.
It's drop in the
bucket to things
that we consider important,
and especially the quality
of life in the world.
So it's important to
keep that in perspective.
We need to maintain momentum
in capital innovation culture.
That's what we have here.
It's growing in other places
around the world as well.
It's important to
foster that growth,
and evolve into a
global society where
we have connections
and shared connections
with groups around the world,
shared interests, and can
leverage each other's strengths.
The rest of the world
is catching up fast
with increased competition.
That's why isolation
won't work in this case.
We do need increased R&D
efforts on key targets.
I think better investments and
smarter choices of technology
is important.
And hopefully, over the
course of the class,
you're equipped with
several of the tools
to make those types
of decisions yourself.
We also need to change
the way we innovate.
Pooled resources,
collaborative efforts,
improved industry-university
lab relations-- which in the US
are somewhat at a precarious
state because of differences
in priorities between
publications and IP protection
and so forth.
Direct to manufacturing
innovations--
instead of always thinking
that startup companies are
the only route, thinking
in terms of how do I
get this technology into a large
established company in the US?
That's a route that we don't
think about very often,
but could have a huge
impact, and certainly has
an impact in Germany.
The need for a steady
predictable market--
all right, I think I might be
asking too much in this bullet
point.
But it would be nice.
And certainly policy can
play a large role in that.
We have enough unpredictability
with oversupply
and undersupply.
We don't need the politicians
getting into it as well,
and changing their
minds every two years.
And investment in
education as well--
the right type of basic
education-- so you can get
involved a number of ways.
And I encourage you to do so.
I thank you for your attention.
And I wish you the best
of fortunes going forward.
Please feel free to call me
whenever you have a need.
And I look forward
to your presentation.
So be well.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]